[Music]
what is EDR the acronym stands for
endpoint detection and response which is
increasingly an essential part of any
competent cyber security strategy over
the next few minutes I'll go through how
it works and why it's so essential these
days I'm Sam Hector from the IBM
security team and what I think EDR is
really doing is endpoint threat
detection and response after all the
point of EDR isn't to go around
detecting all of the laptops phones and
servers on your network but rather it's
to proactively detect threats on those
endpoints when they occur and then
respond to them in real time
to do this effectively it needs to do
four things really well firstly collect
security data from the endpoints using
an agent which is a small lightweight
application that runs on each of these
devices to enable data Gathering
detection and response actions to take
place even when that endpoint isn't
connected to the internet it needs to
collect security relevant Telemetry like
what processes are running what servers
they're connecting to and what files are
being accessed and lots more information
that can be useful to detect the
presence of a threat or to use in
forensic analysis and investigation
after an attack has occurred the second
thing it needs to do is detect and
respond to threats in real time and
automatically it does this mainly in two
different ways one for threats we've
seen before and one for threats we've
never seen when we detect attacks in the
wild security teams can gather what's
called indicators of compromise or iocs
in order to take a unique fingerprint of
a piece of malware like a ransomware
tool that's been around for a while for
example
in this case the EDR can act like the
bouncer on the door of a nightclub
denying entry to a list of Bad actors
before they even get in and
traditionally this is what antivirus
would have been known for doing
but what about threats we've never seen
before or how would an EDR solution
protect against the growing number of
fileless attacks ones which never
download any malicious malware or leave
any Trace well even threats we've never
seen before use similar tactics and
techniques to past attacks we're already
aware of so in order to detect them
without a fingerprint it's a case of
using Advanced algorithms to look for
these behaviors
for example a common method of
Distributing malware is by hiding it in
the macro code of an innocent looking
Microsoft Office file an EDR tool could
stop this by noticing when the Excel
application tries to alter the system's
security settings something it would
never normally need to do so the EDR
tool can block the attempt before it's
successful the third thing it needs to
enable is forensic investigation and
threat hunting because I'm afraid to say
that no EDR tool will stop 100 of
attacks but by capturing lots of
security relevant information they can
help security teams understand how
attacks were successful and how to
change their approach to ensure they're
detected and blocked in the future
this can also enable security teams to
perform threat hunting activities to go
and proactively investigate all of their
endpoints at once for the presence of a
new threat that's not yet detected
automatically so that they can manually
take action to reduce their risk
and finally an EDR tool needs to
integrate and report for a security
analyst it needs to integrate into their
existing workflow because they're often
inundated by alerts they need to triage
from lots and lots of different tools an
EDR should help them prioritize
incidents to look at urgently present
them with all of the potentially
relevant information in a friendly
interface and speak the same language as
other security tools by adopting Common
vernacular like the miter attack
framework
for a security team an EDR tool needs to
integrate with all of their existing
capability and feed additional Telemetry
into a management platform like a Sim
tool for threat detection a saw tool for
instant response or an xdr platform that
combines these capabilities
it also needs to enable reporting both
on the performance of your
organization's mean time to respond to
an attack but also reporting against
compliance to regulatory Frameworks
so to finish if you're looking for an
EDR tool there's a few things that you
should really look out for the best ones
will be highly resilient to attack
ideally by being invisible and
inaccessible to malware that's running
on the operating system
use Advanced AI to learn from the
decisions your analysts have made in the
past and recommend that in future that
alert is automatically handled to
drastically reduce the workload on your
team it should have logging capabilities
that use as little data as possible to
save money on the cost of bandwidth and
it should offer multiple deployment
models between SAS on-prem and even
air-gapped environments to give you as
much flexibility in deployment as
possible
so to talk to IBM about adopting EDR or
optimizing your approach click the link
in the description and get involved in
the comments below check out our other
cyber security videos and subscribe to
see more in the future